children's imaginations can run riot
when they're left to draw but sometimes
they can go into some pretty disturbing
places stay tuned to the end to see how
one kids drawing inspired an artist to
recreate it if this is the first time
you've visited the things then do us a
favor and give this video a thumbs up
and click the subscribe button today we
are going to show you 20 creepy kids
drawings that will make you cringe who's
your friend
one of the sweetest and most popular
drawings a child can do is one of them
and their friends there's a certain
charm and innocence to them that's why
we couldn't help but be rather unnerved
by this next drawing are you ready to
take a look at this picture and see
what's so creepy about it okay here you
go there's a child we think that it
might be a little girl and their best
friend could take another look and
you'll see just what's so disturbing
about it if you look at the friends tone
and its features then you might well
think that this child's best friend is
an alien finish it something that we
learned while doing this is at the
phenomenon of spooky creepy and
unnerving children's drawings is not
something that is confined to the
english-speaking world the next example
is rather disturbing and it comes from
the northern European country of Finland
it's a drawing or rather two drawings
that the artist did when they were just
8 years old the first one is of a
bizarre demonic looking being called
combos but the next one of a creature
called Piru is even creepier the text
next to it translates as he /she
lives inside of you you surrender to him
/her with pleasure he / he is Satan but
that is wrong the taking boy a lot of
the time when we look at creepy kids
drawings you can sometimes work out what
the child is trying to draw of course it
may not have come out as they intended
to but there's often something there
that can be explained with a bit of
thought but we are stumped when trying
to work out what this next picture might
mean there are figures of mommy that
makes sense
daddy which also makes in
and Julian which to make sense however
there's something else that we couldn't
work out and that's away from the family
the dark image of someone or something
called the taking boy no matter how much
we try to think we can work out what it
might mean
who loves mom there is something really
rather sweet about a child writing a
letter to its parent there is something
about it that shows the touching
innocence and sweet naivety combines
with a message of unconditional love and
we are sure that when young Amanda's
father got a note from his daughter
that's what he was expecting to see that
isn't what he saw are you ready to take
a look here we go as you can see Amanda
did a drawing of her father who
evidently has green hair and she left a
rather shocking message the note to her
little drawing says I love mom better
than you Amanda he must have been
shocked life is a water slide who
doesn't like going on a waterslide
we certainly do they're great fun and
for a kid's the experience of a
waterslide inspired this piece of creepy
art here you are it's a drawing it
appears to be inside some kind of card
of a person going through a waterslide
and coming out as an elderly looking man
with a walking stick on it the kid wrote
life is like a waterslide where you die
at the end what makes us think that it
was in a card is that near the end of
the waterslide the kid has written you
are here we really do wonder what the
person who got this thought of it your
teacher does what some time is looking
at one of these children's drawings is
enough to creep us out and make us
cringe however sometimes is the captions
that really unnerve us and with this one
what we can only hope is a simple
spelling error the sort of mistake kids
do all the time is what really disturbs
us as you can see it's a drawing of one
of the child's teachers her name is Miss
Edwards and she's explaining a some in
her head however the child has made a
spelling mistake it says that the kid
likes it when she does meth with us all
we can say is that we really really hope
that they meant math Bella's family one
of the most common drawings that
children do are those of their family we
know that we did it when we were little
and we
reckon that you will have done it too
and that's what little Bella did however
the picture tells us rather more about
her family than we would have thought
they would have liked us to know there's
her brother Logan the family dog Sam and
her parents
however Bella seems to have told us that
most of the family are addicted to
technology Logan is shown holding a DS
game system her dad has got a remote
control and best or worst of all her
mother's head is an Apple laptop this
time when we were kids one of the things
our teachers liked to get us to do was
to draw pictures about what we had been
up to that's what we think one child's
teacher did but we don't think they were
ready for what their people came up with
it looks like a normal picture with the
child their parents and their cats but
look at the figure wearing a top hat on
the right of the drawing and read the
caption today I had a fun time with mum
and dad and the cat even the demon left
us alone this time
there are so many questions to ask about
this but the main one is what do they
mean
this time creepy hair cutting sometimes
kids have no idea what they are doing we
mean that in a nice way of course but
with this next picture we really hope
that the child who drew it had no idea
what they were doing because if they did
then this is seriously creepy this kid
drew a drawing of a girl who sat next to
them in class the kid thought that the
girl was pretty that would be kind of
sweet but not what they said they were
doing they said that because the girl
who sat next to them was pretty they
liked to collect her hair and they drew
a picture of them using scissors to cut
her hair off disturbing or what's a
misspelled Christmas wish something that
we know as adults is that it is very
important to get your spelling right
otherwise you run the risk of either
looking foolish or perhaps worse have
what you've written down misinterpreted
that might well a bit what happened to
one child who wanted to create a sweet
and lovely Christmas card we both think
and hope that they wanted to write I
love Santa in her festive holiday
message but they made a crucial mistake
instead of writing I love Santa the kid
ended up writing I love Satan in
stet well at least we hope that they
just made a mistake
otherwise we suspect they may have been
naughty rather than nice that year
dancing on mommy's grave it is a
terrible terrible thing to lose a parent
it must be even more terrible to lose a
parent as a young child
however for one young artist it doesn't
seem to have been that traumatic of an
experience and that is what makes this
picture so creepy there is a drawing of
a child we aren't sure if it's a boy or
a girl with their father they both have
smiles on their faces and they're
dancing next to a tombstone marked mom
the caption is me plus dad dance alone
mommy's grave the thing that gives this
drawing the added cringe factor is in
the top-left corner even the Sun is
smiling crazy driver we all know that
some substances are bad they make people
who take them do crazy bad and foolish
things
what is encouraging is that one young
kid got the message and wanted to share
it with people but when you look at this
picture you realize that the message is
probably the only thing about it that
wasn't a bit disturbing it's of a man
driving a car and about to run someone
over the victim is shouting help help
the pictures caption describes a person
as a lunatic with unfocused eyes and it
says what he took to make his eyes that
way while we admire the message of this
drawing we do wish it had been done in a
less unnerving way the doorman and the
pencil man it takes a lot of guts to let
your partner look at the drawings you
did when you were a kid and it also
takes a lot of nerve to stay with your
partner if they showed you drawings like
these a woman called Sam visited her
boyfriend's family home and he showed
her a collection of drawings he did when
he was a child in them for two villains
the doorman who throws doorknobs at you
and you die and the pencil man who
throws out lead and erases you
remarkably Sam is still with her
boyfriend no matter how creepy his
youthful artwork was we have to admit it
we like Sam who killed the cats there is
an old saying curiosity killed the cat
but satisfaction brought it back we
don't know if you know that saying but
if you didn't know it then this next
picture will creep the heck out of you
it appears to be some
kind of courtroom scene however all but
one of the people in a picture is
wearing a hat for some reason one person
probably the judge says order in the
court
someone has killed the cat then a suited
figure replies curiosity killed the cat
what gives this picture that added extra
edge is that there is a very sad looking
cat in it but even so it's kind of
creepy
a boy and a flower with this collection
of creepy kids drawings some of them are
clearly a bit disturbing on the first
viewing however with other ones it's
only after letting things sink in that
we start to really feel creeped out and
that is what happened to us when we saw
this next picture as you can see there's
a boy we think it's a boy anyway and
he's walking in a field of some kind
however there are two things which ended
up making us cringe the first one is
that the boy looks like he is about to
step on a flower and that's made it even
worse by the caption which is the word
destroy pretty unnerving we think the
end of humanity when we were children we
were rather disturbed about what could
happen at the end of the world it seems
like not much else has changed because
this picture was from a kid called
Marshall age 7 who foresaw humankind's
end and Marshall saw it in a way which
we are more than willing to admit
creeped us out a fair bit and if you
take a look at it you will see that
there's a person being shocked by a very
large animal and there's a caption which
reads the end of humanity Marshalls
mother Sandra posted on the Internet but
to let us all know what animal it was it
was a giant squirrel an imaginary friend
a lot of children have imaginary friends
this is a perfectly normal part of
growing up
now when one kid's parents found out
that their offspring had an imaginary
friend they asked their offspring to
draw a picture of them and that's where
in this case things got a bit creepy we
can see the kid's self-portrait and it's
the sort of drawing that any child might
end up doing of themselves however we
aren't too sure about the friend this
imaginary friend doesn't have two arms
like most people have they have got 11
arms but that isn't the worst thing
their friend looks as if their head is
falling off star wars are you a fan of
the Star Wars franchise we certainly are
as are a lot of people so when one
eight-year-old girl wanted to make a
card for one of her parents she took
Star Wars as an inspiration however we
aren't sure whether she could have
chosen a more appropriate part of the
Star Wars story for her birthday card
you see the picture in question features
Darth Vader standing next to an imperial
stormtrooper as they shoot someone
however the girl was quite keen to point
out that that wasn't what they wished
for their parent rather thoughtfully
they wrote not you next to the person
being shot which is nice we think
watching you sometimes a picture can be
a bit unnerving but what a kid has
written next to it really up to the
creep factor we think that that is
particularly true of this next drawing
there's something a bit odd about this
picture of an eye maybe it's because we
all have a fear of being watched
well what adds to this is that the child
who drew it has written a caption the
caption says I'm watching you it's hard
to describe why it's so creepy but
there's a certain dark perfection to the
combination of words and picture that
really freaks us out the fact that the
eye is red who really doesn't help
things either a hill a president and an
artist artists get inspiration from
their works from many places but when
artist Devin Clark came across a rather
disturbing drawing by Pablo Blanco 8
called cannibalistic hill he knew he had
to turn it into a piece of art Pablo's
drawings show people being attacked in a
variety of unpleasant ways interestingly
enough one of their victims is former
American president george w bush anyway
Devin was so impressed by Pablo's
drawing that he used his skill to
recreate it in a whole new way Devin
said he could never come up with
something as bizarre and disturbing on
his own but we wondered what art from
your childhood would you like to see
recreated let us know in the comments
and that's all for our 20 creepy kids
drawings that will make you cringe if
you liked this video don't forget to
subscribe and please give it a big
thumbs up thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]